yes give him anything we need to stop
his nervous system is failing no
fashion chess compressions i'm about to
play
bio ink redemption i couldn't play it
before because i didn't
have a computer i mean i had a computer
but not a pc i'm a mac guy
so i got myself a predator triton 500.
it sounds like a transformer the fans
are blowing because my turbo buttons on
and i'm overclocking don't know what any
of that means
sounds legit though choose death and
explore your dark side by
r wrathfully terminating victims choose
life and heroically save your patient
before it's too late
shall i cross over to the darks i don't
know why i'm doing this i'm going to
save death for the end i'm going to
choose life first i want to see what
that's like who needs a tutorial i'm a
doctor
this is a bio game i'm a bio life
sciences
no i have a bio life site
i have a bio life sciences bachelor's
degree so i should know how to play this
game
without a tutorial on life we strongly
advise for you to complete the
short life tutorial to learn the basics
on how to save your patience
oh i've never skipped a tutorial in my
life in fact i'm the guy that's always
judging people for skipping the tutorial
or throwing away the instructions
well like just follow the instructions
it's so easy no name your patient
you know who's old who we desperately
need to keep around who's actually been
on this channel
dr fauci patient dr fauci has a few
diseases targeting his
circulatory and nervous systems and his
overall health is suffering
reach 100 recovery by diagnosing and
treating diseases
okay his heart is bleeding and this is
not realistic but
oh my god i probably should have watched
the tutorial what am i clicking on
oh no i should have watched the tutorial
oh he's bleeding he's muscular without
you you've been lifting bro
i don't understand i don't
i don't god i should have watched the
instructions all right
we're going to have to put a fast
diagnosis on dr fauci and figure out
what's going on here
new symptom confusion oh no dr fauci has
altered mental status
his nervous system is failing let's work
up his brain mri i think a brain mri
will give us some knowledge about what's
going on
brain mri test results hypertension
positive
first of all a brain mri does not tell
you someone's blood pressure
blood clots positive stroke positive
parkinson's positive and you got all
those results from a brain mri
a lot of inaccuracies here but we got to
treat the stroke quickly okay here we go
yoga will help him with his nervous
system and muscular system
we don't have enough points we need two
two more points
all right we have six let's get him to
do some yoga
dr fauci's now practicing yoga perfect
that's that's a good warrior stance
that is a good warrior stance
oh in critical condition dr fauci has
been admitted to the emergency room no
no
i'm not going to let his nervous system
go down intensive care nervous system
evolve dr fauci is receiving an
experimental neuro regeneration therapy
we need to give him tpa
he's having a stroke oh no he's having
leg pain don't worry dr fauci those are
just leg cramps
those are just leg cramps the
circulatory system is also failing
rather quickly
what can i do should i do more of a
diagnosis where's the circulatory system
i don't see it oh we can make him into a
fitness enthusiast
dr fauci is now working out several
hours a week
look at this guy dr fauci's training for
his first triathlon
wow while his circulatory system is
failing and his nervous system probably
not a good idea
that's all right man his nervous system
is at eight percent just hang with me it
was cause in the beginning i didn't know
what to do
six percent no faushi chess compressions
oh we can give him psychiatric
counseling yeah boy
stress management therapy no he needs
antidepressants
no i need three points for
antidepressants give me give me give me
give me give me give me okay i think i
can give him antidepressants now where
are you
antidepressants prescribed let's see if
his nervous system stabilizes a little
bit okay it's getting better
it's getting better oh he has memory
loss now oh no oh no
oh no oh my god he's at four percent one
point four percent two percent oh my god
no
flouchy bouchy voucher just a little
longer just a little longer
dr fauci is drinking alcohol responsibly
okay look at this guy
colon s race inhibitors yes give him
anything we need to
stop his nervousness from his belly no
come on
come on just hang on man oh my
circulatory system failed
oh no he's bleeding come on fouch come
on america needs you
the world needs you brain mri oh there's
the
oh i don't have enough give him aspirin
oh i don't have enough
i could have given him tpa this whole
time dude i didn't know
i probably should have done the tutorial
give him anticoagulants
yeah give him alpha blockers yeah he has
paralysis
now uh he's at one percent i think i'm
going to lose vouchers flatlining chest
compressions
parkinson's disease caused dr fauci's
nervous system to collapse
first which then led his circulatory
system to collapse
[Music]
we should have started on someone silly
oh my god my nose is bleeding
look how sad i am for bouchy
all right we're gonna do that again now
that i know what i'm doing i'm thinking
tiger king
should we go joe exotic or should we go
carol baskin
it's sad but i'm about to save joe
exotic better than i did dr fauci
i should have probably started with joe
exotic
oh boy this is not gonna go well so i'm
gonna build up all the bio points and
then right away we're going to start
improving his lifestyle let's get jugs
out to relax a little bit he's a little
wound up let's get him doing a little
yoga
let's start the diagnosis he has some
muscle weakness muscle weakness can be a
sign of like kidney stuff so let's look
at kidney stuff let's do a urinalysis
let's do a full physical exam let's see
if he actually has weakness
i need the results he has no
gastroenteritis he has no muscle cramps
and he has no androgenic alopecia
that is male pattern baldness let's give
him
another workup for his muscles and run
a metabolic panel no sepsis no kidney
failure no uti
no all port syndrome that's very
specific can't see can people look it up
if you don't believe me okay
no cholesterol no potassium deficiency
no diabetes no pancreatitis no
hemophilia
this is a healthy guy right here his
nervous system's failing
what conditions can cause the nervous
system and the circulatory system to
fail
simultaneously that's interesting
oh a stroke duh let's get a brain mri in
here
run test oh parkinson's disease
makes a lot of sense no stroke no
aneurysm though so we need to give him
carbidopa and levodopa
okay and then i i really want to figure
out what's going on with his
circulatory system so let's go ahead and
run a blood pressure test and see if he
has high blood pressure oh he has high
blood pressure we should treat that new
disease found hypertension let's give
them
alpha blockers they're going to be more
effective and quicker and he's going
down
quick personality changes
personality changes let's run the ekg
because the circulatory system is
failing way too quick
for my liking no he's not having a heart
attack
what is going on with his heart let's
boost his
circulatory system here evolved
joe exotic had a heart transplant his
health increased by 25
thank god but now his muscles are
failing we need to find another disease
muscular muscular muscular where are we
here we go ffma test
oh fibromyalgia no way he has
fibromyalgia
and he's dying from it that's not a
deadly illness
and now he has an irregular heartbeat
how am i supposed to keep him alive
he's in the emergency room come on i'm
just gonna run a bunch of tests we need
to figure out what's wrong with him
he's not he doesn't have fibromyalgia
none of the muscular diseases make sense
and he doesn't have an insomnia or
hemiparesis then why is he dying
i can't think and click at the same time
like what
other tests can i run infectious disease
thing
let's do some chest x-rays can i slow
the game down
okay he's not having any lung issues he
has no infectious disease
what is going on what do you have oh no
his systems are failing
i i've run oh no no
no my game exited i got it back what do
you have joe exotic
i just i can't i've done every test
oh what is male let's do ultrasounds
okay he has blood clots he has blood
clots we can treat those and he has
testicular cancer
oh no oh no they want to take away his
testicles
okay all right we did the testicles
let's see if he could survive
oh no he died joe
i am never going to financially recover
from this
baskin i'm going for the baskin carol
baskin now i know i know you gotta
diagnose right away
or you gotta put all your effort into
making him as healthy as possible or her
as healthy as possible her circulatory
system is the worst
followed by nervous system i know what
to think now and i'm gonna start with
the female
psychological evaluation she clearly
needs it
probably smell her oh she has chronic
stress and a nervous breakdown probably
because she killed her husband
we gave her stress management therapy
gonna give her psychiatric counseling
all right now let's run some tests let's
do a blood pressure and let's do a blood
pressure metabolic panel
and a neurological exam run test oh she
has hypertension let's open biomap
hypertension we would want to treat that
but we have no points so
let's collect some points oh she has
high cholesterol we can treat that too
and we can upgrade and we can harvest
faster now see now i'm learning how to
play this game
all for carl carl baskin her name is not
carl basket
i have a feeling i'm going to save her i
need 18 points for her to have good
genetics because i feel like then we can
get her across the finish line all right
here we go
we have enough to get her good genetics
oh no her nervous system is failing uh
let's do a brain mri
oh she has a stroke and blood clot and
parkinson's how do we treat it let's see
if we can treat
her her parkinson's i can't treat her
parkinson's what about the stroke we can
treat the stroke
yes oh she's in the emergency room we
need to get
three more points and then we could
probably save her here we go
come on we got to be able to help her
out oh my god his nervous system's still
failing oh maybe it's something with the
females do a mammogram but that wouldn't
affect her nervous system what else can
i check
i'm trying everything oh she has breast
cancer that's the most excited i've ever
been
about that diagnosis i don't think she's
gonna she's at 65
if i just help her a little bit
everything's coming up negative that's
the problem
oh my god she's falling apart no no oh
no oh no oh no let's see
female pelvic exam run test
aha she has polycystic ovarian syndrome
which we're going to treat
with oral contraceptives i just don't
understand what she can have
maybe i'm playing this too medically no
no she's in pain she's suffering
i'm desperate because i don't know how
to help her she doesn't have
any of these symptoms
she died i don't know how to play this
and she died faster than everyone else
died
she had parkinson's disease but i looked
for parkinson's disease
i don't get it
i think basically what i have to do is
play the death version of this game
so if you want me to play the death
version of this game get this video to
100 000 likes and check out me playing
play gink
i actually created a virus very similar
to kova19 and check out this video here
where i played
sims but i made myself in the game and
bear
and try to go through med school which
one you're clicking on as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]